if you want to hear my theory about what
Chucky's original plan may have been and
how it was altered in desperation then
stick around to the end of this video
and welcome back to things you missed
the show where I find the most
thoughtful and intelligent analysis and
discussion about horror cinema except
recovering a movie about a dumb kid and
a killer doll who at one point blows up
a house so let's just throw all that
intelligent analysis stuff out the
window with Aunt Maggie and get into the
things you missed the movie begins in
Chicago where serial killer Charles Lee
ray is fleeing from the police
I heard online somewhere that the name
Charles Lee ray comes from combining the
names of serial killer Charles Manson
and assassins Lee Harvey Oswald and
James Earl Ray and I only wish that he
actually would succeeded in taking over
Andy Barclays body because that would
have made him Charles Barkley apparently
before Jimmy Wong was Anfisa fiction he
also ran his own Cantonese restaurant
outside of which Charles Lee ray gets
shot anyone find it a little strange
that he bleeds more in his doll form
than he does as a human
[Music]
anyways he flees into the toy shop and
one thing I found kind of interesting
here is that the front window of this
place Playland toys shows all of these
toys driving cars and that's like the
one thing that Chucky can't do and all
of the sequels he has to either hitch a
ride or threaten someone and drive him
somewhere there's also a picture of
Humpty Dumpty right here next to this
French duck and that could be a
foreshadowing about Maggie falling down
the 8th story window later that could
just be a coincidence but I will note
that this wasn't just a toy store that
they filmed in this was built for the
movie and also destroyed for the movie
when Rey is breaking into the store
there's a game near the window called
fireball Island which from what I can
tell is a game about a cursed volcano
and Charles shoots in that direction to
open the door this could be a parallel
to Chucky being cursed doll who's
eventually killed when I shoot it in the
hearts again those are questionably
intentional but here's one that
definitely isn't intentional but I found
kind of interesting anyways when the
title comes on-screen all of the letters
are capitalized besides a and I and in
the 2019 version of child's play Chucky
is an AI in artificial intelligence as
the dying Charles makes his way through
the store he keeps saying he's got to
find somebody
[Music]
then when he knocks over the stack of
good guy dolls he looks surprised as if
an idea has just hit him I think he
memorized the Voodoo incantation with
the intention of transferring his soul
into another human in case he ever got
in trouble but since there were no
humans around he figured his best bet
was to try to send it into the doll and
by a stroke of luck it worked he even
tells John Bishop later that he was kind
of surprised that it worked the next day
is our protagonist Andy Barclays
birthday he gets up early to watch his
favorite show and good guys Rolex no but
what I actually wanted to point out was
that the kid in this cartoon has a
target on his chest just as Andy becomes
the target of Chucky after learning that
he's the only one that he'll be able to
transfer his soul into Andy isn't
interested in the show though because
he's apparently already seen it so he
returns to the kitchen so he continued
being a complete brat
[Music]
the brand of bread that he uses for his
mother's toasts is good stuff which
matches the constant good guys branding
on almost everything he owns I'm
genuinely surprised that they didn't
make this good guys mascot the villain
of the entire movie instead of the doll
he looks way creepier look at this thing
imagine this chasing after you in a dark
alley would have been way better at the
end of that commercial we hear good guys
and other fine toys found in toy stores
throughout the Greater Chicago area
playpals would later play a more
prominent role in the sequel child's
play too though there looks to be an
error later in the movie where it says
play partners toys on the good guys box
instead of play pals close enough I
guess speaking of errors when Andy sees
that commercial that's the first time
he's hearing about the good guy doll
then he goes into the other room and
wakes up his mom and she lets him open
his birthday presents well what do you
think I don't know good guy to go with
say I know you do Andy wait hold up stop
it right there no no you didn't know he
wanted a good guy he just found out like
five minutes ago while you were asleep
alright let's continue Andy's mom is
able to buy the doll from a peddler and
give it to Andy the design of the good
guy doll is based off the my buddy doll
from the eighties
[Music]
Andy's mom has to work late so her
friend Maggie watches and Yvette nights
as she's turning off the TV and news
report talks about Eddie Caputo who
escaped during a prison bus transfer on
his way to court you'll already know
about this if you've seen the movie
multiple times but it's not as obvious
on the first watch
Eddie was Charles accomplice the night
before at the toy store who bailed out
on picking him up in the van so Chuckie
goes after him later and blows up his
hideout
also the news station is called wdol you
know because Chuck uses a doll Chucky
pushes Maggie out of the window where
she falls harder than James Charles
career
so Karen ends up coming home into an
apartment full of cops wait how are you
surprised by that after this and this
[Music]
and after this sparkly I'm detective
Mike Norris homicide so the cops clear
out after he explains everything and the
next day Karen takes her son to school
and lets him bring the Chucky doll with
this is almost as bad as that kid who
brought his cat to school and pet
sematary - yeah this video really took a
wrong turn if we're talking about Pet
Sematary - again Andy skipped school and
Chucky makes him go to Eddie's hideout
so he can get his revenge the police
find Andy and pick him up where they
discover he believes that Chucky is
alive and send him in for a mental
evaluation Karen is left to give Chucky
a closer look at the apartment there's a
photo of a guy in a red shirt I'm
guessing that supposed to be Andy's
deceased father and they have the same
photo all over the house but it's
actually just the director of the
movement Tom Holland he also makes a
cameo as the voice during that creepy
commercial that I mentioned earlier
Chucky tries to kill officer Norris and
is almost successful but Norris ends up
shooting him and Chucky discovers that
he's able to feel pain so he hits up his
pal John Bishop the voodoo doctor to try
to figure out how to remedy the
situation he learns that his doll form
is becoming human and Chucky threatens
him with a voodoo doll to try to get
more information tell your customers
where you hide things like this John
wait so are we to believe that John made
a voodoo doll of himself
why how how would that you know what it
was just continue on with this video
John and so Chucky learns he must
transfer his soul into the person who he
first revealed himself to which of
course is Andy
so Chucky tries to break into the
hospital where the world is being kept
and all of a sudden he's freaking
massive on the stairs look at this it's
like that mascot I was talking about
earlier and are we really supposed to
believe that Andy the kid who could not
even pour a bowl of his cereal properly
was clever enough to set that bait with
the pillow and escape when Chucky came
in and one more thing why do they have
this shock device which is apparently
capable of killing a grown man in a
Children's Hospital and another thing
how does a six-year-old find his way
home on the streets of Chicago by
himself and it's winter and I'm assuming
he's never been to this hospital before
all right I'll stop ragging on this
movie now no obvious reference to
Halloween obvious reference to the
shining Andy's mom gets home and manages
to trap Chucky in the fireplace and we
actually get a pretty cool one-liner
from hand
it isn't
they blow check his head off and he
comes back they blow his arm off and he
comes back and then finally they figure
it out for some reason you have to shoot
it in the heart cue the Bon Jovi and
credits em what no shot through the
heart are you kidding me this was the
80s that song came out like two years
before this it would have been perfect
alright whatever
click the video on the left if you want
to see some things you missed in the
teaser trailer and Arg for the new
child's play remake next week I'm doing
child to play two and three and of
course I'll be doing the new movie when
it comes out so here's what you gotta do
subscribe to see these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]